>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Joel Achenbach: Thank
you for being here.
I'm Joel Achenbach with the
Washington Post with Joseph Mazur,
the author of this fabulous book
"Fluke", the subtitle is "The Math
and Myth of Coincidence".
And we're going to talk
about coincidences and flukes
and serendipity and
things like that.
And we're just going
to shoot the breeze
and then we'll go up to questions.
Please ask whatever is on your mind.
I promise you that if you read the
book, you'll be better at Vegas,
you're going to win the lottery.
I mean--
>> Joseph Mazur: Now, wait a
second, I don't promise that.
>> Joel Achenbach: This is-- you'll
know about the magic numbers, OK.
No, actually the other
way around but, so.
So, Dr. Mazur who has a PhD in
Mathematics from MIT is a professor
at Marlboro College in
Vermont, professor emeritus.
He's written a whole bunch of books.
One is called "What's
Luck Got to Do with It"
which is actually about gambling.
He's written "The Motion Paradox",
subtitle is "The 2,500-Year-Old
Puzzle Behind the Mysteries
of Time and Space".
OK. So he's got that figured out.
OK. All right.
He's very smart, very
smart guy, time and space.
I think he can answer any question.
>> Joseph Mazur: Uh-oh,
be careful what--
>> Joel Achenbach: He's
written a book called "Euclid
in the Rainforest: Discovering
Universal Truth in Logic and Math"
and a book called,
"Enlightening Symbols".
So, he is a-- Joe, you're--
can I call you Joe, Dr. Mazur?
>> Joseph Mazur: Yes,
please, please, please.
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
You'd call me Mr. Achenbach.
He's a popularizer of mathematics.
He's written these books so that--
so people could understand math
and probabilities and I
guess, you know, risk analysis
and just how the world
works a little bit better.
Let's talk about this book
"Fluke" and you have a whole bunch
of stories in here that are
about amazing coincidences
and you explained how it's
possible for these things to happen.
Let's talk about the Anthony Hop--
the famous Anthony Hopkins
coincidence where he came
across the-- it was the
book, The Girl from--
>> Joseph Mazur: Petrovka.
>> Joel Achenbach: Petrovka, OK.
Tell that story.
>> Joseph Mazur: Yeah, OK.
The story goes like
this and this is partly
from Anthony Hopkins' version.
The story is that back in 1976
when Anthony Hopkins was not very
well-known, a fledgling actor,
and he got the part in a movie
called "The Girl from Petrovka".
And he wanted to get the novel.
He had the script, he wanted
the novel and reads the novel.
Now the novel was an
American edition of the novel
but it had not come out in
Britain at the time and he lived
in Britain and near London.
He decided to go one day to search
for the-- for a copy of the novel.
Now, this is 1976,
there's no Amazon.
You know, you have to-- you can
call bookstores but you really have
to do some leg work to
find books at that point.
So, he spends a day searching
hundreds of bookstores according
to him and finds no book that
satisfies him and he comes home.
Oh, he comes back to the tube stop
that he generally uses
to get back home.
>> Joel Achenbach: Tube is what
they call the subway over there.
>> Joseph Mazur: The subway, yeah.
>> Joel Achenbach: It's just train--
>> Joseph Mazur: The underground,
they call it underground.
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: I'm not sure of
the reason for that, but anyhow.
They-- He sits on a bench
and for a few minutes,
he's sitting on the
bench and he just happens
to notice some other
things on the bench
and among the other things
is a book and he moves
over to search what this book is
and the book is the exact book,
"The Girl from Petrovka", that
he'd been looking for all day.
Now, that is essentially his version
but there is another version,
slightly different version,
and I heard the actual story
from George Feifer
who is the novelist.
So, that is one story about a book.
And what I do in the book is
to take all coincidence stories
that I've ever heard of and classify
them into 10 different classes
and then take a good representative
of each of the classes.
So you have 10 stories now
instead of hundreds of stories.
You now have 10.
This is what mathematicians
do, by the way.
You know, they classify things.
I mean, if I were really worried
about dealing with, let's say,
the whole numbers,
all those numbers,
I might not be interested
in all the numbers.
I can't visualize all the numbers
really, but I can visualize,
let's say, the numbers that
are multiples of three.
And what do I do when I
have multiples of three?
I only think of three and
then I might think of 3N.
And so, I have all of
the multiples of three.
There are an infinite number of
them since I can't visualize them,
but that's exactly what
I do in the stories.
So, I'm actually taking the
10 stories as representatives
of 10 classes of stories.
Now there's another
story also about a book.
>> Joel Achenbach: OK, so wasn't
the book he found the book
that belongs to the author?
>> Joseph Mazur: That's
part-- that's right.
Two years later.
>> Joel Achenbach:
Incredibly unlikely, right?
>> Joseph Mazur: Incredibly
unlikely.
Two years later, two years
later, he's on the movie set
and George Feifer is there
and Anthony Hopkins comes
up to George Feifer and he said,
you know, I found a book, you know,
he tells him the story and George
said did the book have red markings
on all of the British
words that were--
all the American words that could be
translated into British spellings?
And Hopkins said yes.
And it turns out to
be George's book.
So there's the-- it's
a kind of a second part
of that particular story.
>> Joel Achenbach: And what
class of coincidence is that?
>> Joseph Mazur: It's a whole
class of coincidences that are
of searching for things
and then not--
and then finding them in
very unexpected places
and that's a whole
class of stories that--
>> Joel Achenbach: And then
there's the Anne Parrish story.
>> Joseph Mazur: There's
an Anne Parrish story.
Anne Parrish was a children's
book writer in the 19th--
well, early 20th Century.
She and her husband, Charles
Corliss, were vacationing in Paris.
She lives in Philadelphia or she
lived in Philadelphia at that time.
She was born in Colorado.
She's in Paris.
The two of them were sipping wine
in Deux Magots and she wanders,
while her husband is still
sitting sipping wine,
she wanders over to the Seine, about
eight minutes walk, and she rummages
through the bookstalls, finds
a book called "Jack Frost
and Other Stories" and she's
so delighted with this.
She buys it for a franc,
runs to her husband
and says this was my favorite
book when I was a child.
And he opens the book and sees
in the-- on the first few pages,
a scribbling of a child's
handwriting
and it's the address of Anne.
Whenever I tell the story by
the way, my spine tingles.
I have to tell you that it
really is spine-tingling
because it is another one
of those really rare things
that happen but it does happen.
Now--
>> Joel Achenbach: What are the--
so what are the odds of that?
So when something really,
really unlikely happens--
>> Joseph Mazur: Yes,
it is unlikely.
>> Joel Achenbach: -- how
should we interpret that?
>> Joseph Mazur: OK.
There are two ways
of interpreting it.
One is if I'm thinking in
retrospect that it is this person,
Anne Parrish, and I'm going to
label a person who is going to--
that a particular coincidence
is going to happen to, you--
and then figure out the odds,
you get a very unlikely odds.
In other words, the odds are
extremely against it happening.
It's extraordinarily
against it happening.
But what if you ask in a
slightly different way?
What if you say, what are the
odds of somebody coming to Paris
from America and finding in a
bookstore a book that belonged
to that person as a child?
You get a different sort of odds now
because now you have to say, well,
there are a lot of
people who are traveling,
a lot of people have books, a
lot of people have, you know,
find books from their childhood.
And I think it happens
very often in fact.
There are many of these coincidences
that once you drop the retrospective
idea, that is you're taking it
in as a big global world of
people and events that happen.
So, you know, we have 7
billion people in this world
and so much time is passing by
and so many events are colliding.
It's bound to happen.
I'm suggesting that in fact, we--
these things are happening
all the time,
we just don't hear the stories.
But once we hear the stories
they become magnificent.
So the stories are really
what I want to focus on.
But it is-- the odds
are different for--
it depends on how you
ask the question.
>> Joel Achenbach: So, as a
mathematician, do you have to take
into account, so Anne Parrish goes
to the bookstalls, she finds a book
that has-- she doesn't realize until
she takes it back to her husband.
It has her name and her home address
from when she was a little
girl in Colorado, right?
>> Joseph Mazur: That's right.
>> Joel Achenbach: So do you--
can you mathematically represent
all the other people who shopped
in those bookstalls who didn't
find a book from their childhood?
>> Joseph Mazur: That's the point.
I think that's part of the point.
>> Joel Achenbach: And I
mean there's a famous--
is it Richard Feynman who
said you're never going
to believe what happened
to me this morning?
What? He goes absolutely
nothing, you know.
And it is-- and so the-- we don't--
we focus on the anomalies and,
of course, we don't calculate
every other thing that happened
in this world with 7 billion people.
So, a lot of it is there's 7
billion people all doing stuff--
>> Joseph Mazur: That's right.
>> Joel Achenbach: -- that you
would expect close to a certainty
that on any given day
something unbelievably bizarre
and coincidental would
happen, is that right?
>> Joseph Mazur: That's correct.
That's absolutely correct
and it's all in the noticing.
That's the point.
But now if you look at these
stories and you really want
to know why they happened,
whenever you're told a story,
you're only told the
shell of the story,
you're really told the shell of it.
The storyteller does not really tell
you the ingredients that are going
to give you the connections
that will happen in order
to make that story come true.
So for example, you know, I always
think of these things when I start
to analyze one of the stories
and believe me, I've got over 450
of these stories and
emails and all sorts
of things that are coming at me.
I'm the repository of coincidence
stories and I get them everyday now.
And what I have-- what
people are asking me
to do is what you just asked
me to do is to analyze them.
Well, here is what you
have to think about.
The story is in a shell, I think
of it as in a Russian troika doll
and you have to open the first
doll to see the next doll.
The problem with this
is that this is--
usually in Russian troika dolls,
there are only a finite
number of nested dolls.
In many of these stories, especially
the fabulous coincidence stories,
the number is infinite.
I mean, it just-- you don't know
when you've gotten to
the last troika doll.
And what I mean by that is
I can take, for example,
I can take the Anne Parrish
story and try to break that down.
If you think about-- I did mention
that Charles Corliss was her husband
and you'd think when the
storyteller first tells you that,
well, what does that mean?
Does that mean anything?
Charles Corliss?
It turns out that it does.
It really does.
And what it means is that
if you look and try to find
out who Charles Corliss
is, he's a very rich man
and he has to be a real rich man.
How many people in 1927
could just take off--
remember, there's no
air flights to Paris.
You can't fly to Paris.
>> Joel Achenbach:
Well, Lindbergh did.
Didn't he?
>> Joseph Mazur: No
commercial flights before 1939.
>> Joel Achenbach: That's right.
>> Joseph Mazur: None.
And so, you had to go by boat.
That's the only way, or a balloon
maybe but that would take longer.
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: So,
you had to go by boat.
Now you'd think what does that
have to do with the story?
Well, what it does have to do is--
the question is how did they get
to Paris and what would
it be like for somebody
in her economic position
to go to Paris?
She's going for a vacation.
She's actually-- She's going to
have to spend at least a month,
possibly two months in traveling.
That's different than
the way we travel.
So she's there for a long time.
That may not have been the
first time she was rummaging
through the stalls and she's going
through a lot of different
sequences.
It turns out that she's
gone every other year.
I looked this up in ship manifests.
She's on-- She and her husband
went every other year to Paris.
That's what people in that class
of-- in that economic class did.
You could go to Greece,
you could go to Paris.
They didn't go to many other places.
So, if her book was--
>> Joel Achenbach: It changes
the denominator, right?
>> Joseph Mazur: It changes the
denominator but there's more--
there are more ingredients.
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: So for
example, when you start
to take the next doll out,
you find that her mother,
whose name was also Anne,
happened to be a painter who is
in school with Mary Cassatt.
Mary Cassatt is a very
well-known impressionist painter.
She was young at the time
when she went to school
in Pennsylvania, in Philadelphia.
And they were very close
friends at the time.
So, there's another little
ingredient, two close friends, OK.
Well, Mary spends the
rest of her life
at a very young age
in her 20s in Paris.
She comes back and forth
because she's also very wealthy.
>> Joel Achenbach: Yeah.
>> Joseph Mazur: These
are wealthy people.
And she comes back and forth.
She's very close to her mother.
She dies in 1927, two years before
Anne Parrish finds the book.
I suspect that the book seemed
to travel within the family line.
It went from her mother to Anne--
to Mary Cassatt and Mary Cassatt,
when she died, her
estate was just, you know,
people just didn't know
what to do with books.
You give it to a Paris bookstall
or Shakespeare and Company,
the only two bookstores in Paris
that had any English
speaking-- English books.
>> Joel Achenbach: Right.
>> Joseph Mazur: So, you know,
you start to unravel these things.
You find they are really--
you connect the dots.
You're connecting the
dots all along.
And when you start to connect the
dots, each of those dots has an odd,
in other words, you can attach a
probability to each of those dots.
And once you do, all you have
to do is multiply all those
probabilities together.
You can get some kind of an odds as
to how likely a story would happen.
>> Joel Achenbach: Right.
So, but still not inevitable
that it was going to happen
but not as insanely unlikely.
So, we'll talk about, if you
would, the story of Joan Ginther
who won the lottery four times.
>> Joseph Mazur: Yeah, yeah.
OK. I'm going to go out and--
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: --
I'm going to tell you.
I'm going to tell you that I
believe there are many people
who win the lottery four times.
How's that?
>> Joel Achenbach: Really?
OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: I'm not
surprised and I'll tell you why.
Now, before I tell you why, I
have to-- I have to sort of say,
you know, don't get me wrong.
I don't want to kill
all these stories.
These stories are wonderful,
they're beautiful stories.
And so, I hate putting
numbers on stories
and that's not the point here.
The point is, you know, when
you're talking about coincidences,
you have to think about the
definition of coincidence,
what is the definition
of coincidence?
Definition is, for me, it's
events colliding in space and time
that have a surprise
but no apparent cause.
So that's very, you know,
that makes it clear.
>> Joel Achenbach:
Is it the same thing
as a fluke or is that different?
>> Joseph Mazur: It's a
little different than a fluke.
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: A fluke, the cause
is a little bit more apparent.
I mean they-- it just
happen and then you find it
and you'll see what is
that apparent cause.
You can analyze that cause.
But here, once you know the cause,
it's no longer a coincidence
because it's causal.
>> Joel Achenbach: Right.
>> Joseph Mazur: But when I
say apparent cause, I really--
that word apparent is
kind of a little vague
because you have to
say apparent to whom?
I mean it's-- I mean some
scientists might know the cause
but you don't see the cause.
So, you have to think
of it that way.
Now, when you're talking about Joan
Ginther winning the lottery four
times, then you can
actually put the odds to it.
I mean you know how-- you know what
the odds of winning the lottery is.
That's, you know, the--
>> Joel Achenbach: Did she
buy a lot of lottery tickets?
Did she buy a, I mean like
a million lottery tickets?
>> Joseph Mazur: We don't know that.
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: But we
do know that, you know,
she was a mathematician
from Stanford.
That might help but
I'm not sure it does.
There are ways of cheating
the lottery.
There are a few.
>> Joel Achenbach:
Can you tell us now?
We want to hear that actually, yeah.
>> Joseph Mazur: Well,
I'll tell you in a minute.
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: I'll
tell you one way, anyhow.
The first time she won the
lottery, she won $5 million.
Now, anybody winning
the lottery $5 million
and I've studied this actually for
one of my other books on gambling.
When you win $5 million,
that's house money.
When it's house money, you feel
free to use it the way you want.
What are you going to do?
You want to win again.
That's a high.
Winning $5 million is such
a high for some people.
You win $5 million.
She's going to bet like crazy.
She is going to spend a
couple of years, you know,
dumping her cash this way and that.
And I'm sure she put
possibly a million,
possible 2 million
back into the lottery.
So, she wins again.
Now her odds are terrific to get it.
>> Joel Achenbach: Did she quit
her job as a mathematics professor?
>> Joseph Mazur: I don't know.
I tried to interview her.
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: She
is very reclusive.
I cannot, yeah.
>> Joel Achenbach: So she
goes back in, she reloads
and then she wins three more times.
>> Joseph Mazur: Three more times.
Second time I think
it was $2 million
and next time it was $3 million
and then the fourth
time was $10 million.
>> Joel Achenbach: Wow.
>> Joseph Mazur: Yeah.
Now, the last three, I have
to say, were scratch-offs.
So now, there's a little difference
because with the scratch-off
there are some techniques.
You wait. There's a
certain waiting technique.
You wait until you know
that somebody has not win--
won a certain number
in a certain area
because these scratch-offs are not--
there are little cards that
have been printed in advance
and they're being handed out
not quite randomly, because,
you know, that's another topic.
There's nothing random
in the world really.
So--
>> Joel Achenbach: I think
that's the point of the book.
Actually, it did.
>> Joseph Mazur: It is.
>> Joel Achenbach: Yeah.
That's right.
>> Joel Achenbach: Well,
everything is random.
>> Joseph Mazur: Nothing's random.
>> Joel Achenbach: And
there's no true luck.
>> Joseph Mazur: There's no true--
>> Joel Achenbach: There's
no force of luck in--
>> Joseph Mazur: Well,
now you're getting
into something that's much tougher
for me when you talk about luck.
>> Joel Achenbach: Are
some people just lucky?
What? I interrupted you.
You keep going on the lottery.
>> Joseph Mazur: You
want to talk about luck?
That's fine.
I could talk about luck.
Luck is a different
kind of position.
Most people think of luck as
something that is an object.
You know, you take a rabbit's foot.
That's an object.
It's a symbol of luck and it's
kind of a representative of luck,
you know, as you're
representing luckiness.
If you fail with your, you
know, you fail to be lucky
with your rabbit's foot, you
know, there's a lot of blame to go
around because, you know, a
rabbit's foot to really truly--
truly lucky with a rabbit's
foot, it has to be from a rabbit
that was caught in a
cemetery and it has
to be the left foot of the rabbit.
People may not know
this but that is true.
>> Joel Achenbach: Who knew that?
>> Joseph Mazur: Why the left foot?
>> Joel Achenbach: No
one, no one knew that.
No, yeah.
>> Joseph Mazur: Well,
left foot because--
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: -- sinistra,
the Latin or the Italian word
for leftness which of course
is also our word for sinister.
So, there's this leftness
that is in the equation.
And the reason it's in the equation
is because if for some reason
that rabbit's foot didn't
work to give you that luck,
you blame it on the cemetery.
Oh, it wasn't found in the cemetery.
Oh, you know, I better get
a different rabbit's foot.
So that's built in
to the whole thing.
It's beautifully built in.
I think it's great.
>> Joel Achenbach:
So, may I ask you,
so in our lives we're constantly
calculating the odds of things.
We do risk analysis
all the time, you know.
Is it safe to get on that airplane?
You know, should I worry about, you
know, an asteroid hitting the earth?
Should I, you know, how do I think
about, you know, global warming
or the risk, I mean I hate to
bring this up, a risk of, you know,
a mad person, you know, charging
into a workplace, whatever.
How does mathematics help
us make sense of the world?
>> Joseph Mazur: It's, you
know, risk is primordial.
I mean, it's a question
of do I leave the cave?
And because, you know,
do I leave it now?
I don't know if there's
some saber-toothed tiger
around the corner that's going
to just attack me for lunch.
And so, there is that riskiness
of just leaving the cave.
So it's within us.
We just have been like that
for, you know, millennia,
for many, many thousands of years.
We have developed that feeling
of being cautious about things
and we know that we-- the
risk is all around us.
We feel that.
But to answer your question
about the mathematics, yes,
the mathematics comes from about
the 17th Century mathematics already
risk analysis.
So that's there, I
mean we can actually--
we can have some kind of a
connection between what is real
in the world, what's happening
really in the world, and what is--
what we can actually do as
mathematically modeling that.
And there is this connection.
It's not exact by the way.
I mean you can predict
things totally by mathematics
but you can get a handle on it.
>> Joel Achenbach:
Why didn't evolution
and natural selection
make us better at math?
And I mean, like we're good at a
lot of things, but you've been--
I don't think you have
an equation in this book
for about 50 pages almost because
you know it will scare the readers.
>> Joseph Mazur: That's right.
>> Joel Achenbach: Right?
>> Joel Achenbach: So, I mean
we're not instinctively great
at math, why is that?
>> Joseph Mazur: You're asking
the wrong person to answer that.
>> Joel Achenbach: You spend
your life making this--
trying to make it better, right?
>> Joseph Mazur: Yeah, yeah, yeah,
sure, I understand the question.
I don't understand the answer.
>> Joel Achenbach: Yeah.
All right.
Well, we're going to go to
questions here in a few minutes.
Let's talk about another one of your
stories which is many people here--
another one about Abraham Lincoln.
This is actually in the movie,
the recent movie by Spielberg.
>> Joseph Mazur: It's true.
It's a true story.
>> Joel Achenbach: That Abraham
Lincoln had this dream shortly
before he's assassinated where
he, I guess, walks in a hall
and he sees everyone in
mourning and there's a,
I guess, a coffin or something--
>> Joseph Mazur: OK, yeah.
>> Joel Achenbach: -- and they said
the president has been assassinated.
He had that dream shortly
before it actually happen.
>> Joseph Mazur: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Joel Achenbach:
So talk to us sort
of from a mathematician standpoint.
Was he being clairvoyant or
is this something that is--
that has a high level
of probability?
>> Joseph Mazur: We all have dreams
that-- and we have many of them.
We have a lifetime of dreams.
Many of them we don't remember,
many of them we don't wake up
and we don't think we've dreamt.
But there are so many dreams that
we've had as a collection of people
and you have to think about
the whole idea of how many
of those dreams actually come
true to us and how many do not.
Now, that's a significant one.
He's a president.
He was a president.
He had this dream of
his own assassination.
It's a wonderful story, by the way.
You know, it's been
documented many times.
But I suspect-- I'm just going to
go out on a limb here but I suspect
that almost every president
has a dream like that.
I suspect there is a fear
of being assassinated.
There's got to be.
>> Joel Achenbach: Right.
>> Joseph Mazur: And so
I'm just going to suspect
that every president has a
dream, every important person
who has some kind of
a risk, you know,
some risk that is happening is going
to have a dream and
it doesn't happen.
But sometimes, it does happen.
So there is what you--
that's the equation.
That's where you have to look at.
>> Joel Achenbach: And we have
sort of a hindsight bias of locking
on to the ones where
there's an apparent causality
or clairvoyance and we--
>> Joseph Mazur: That's right.
>> Joel Achenbach: --
ignore the other ones.
>> Joseph Mazur: That's right.
I mean, we know it because
he was assassinated.
>> Joel Achenbach: Right.
>> Joseph Mazur: And
now we can retrofit it
to the mathematics if you want.
>> Joel Achenbach: This is really
a crazy out there question but,
you know, I mean I'm not being
paid for this so I'm going
to go, you know, I'm just--
>> Joseph Mazur: Neither am I.
>> Joel Achenbach: You
know, we're not being paid,
so we're just going
to weigh I think.
So, what are the odds
that we're here?
OK. What I mean by that is, you
know, that intelligence was one
of these adaptive traits that
emerged from evolution which emerged
from 3.5, 4 billion years
of evolution on earth.
I mean, have you ever kind of
looked at that like the odds of--
>> Joseph Mazur: The odds of being
here right now is one minus the odds
of our not being here.
[ Laughter ]
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: Is that all right?
>> Joel Achenbach: Yeah.
>> Joseph Mazur: That would do.
>> Joel Achenbach: Does anyone--
everybody understand that?
OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: I mean I'm serious
about this because, you know,
once you do that, when you're
asked what are the odds
of this happening you have
to also ask what are the
odds of it not happening?
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: I actually
got this question from somebody
when I was doing a reading and
he said, you know, you're talking
about coincidences and
you're talking about the odds
of coincidence happening
but isn't the thing
that doesn't happen
also a coincidence?
So that was, you know,
and it struck me that,
you know, this guy is right.
It is. It's coincidence.
>> Joel Achenbach: All right.
>> Joseph Mazur: Because if I
don't know the apparent cause
of the coincidence, because
that's what the definition
of the coincidence is, then surely
I don't know the apparent cause
of the coincidence not happening.
Because if I did know
the apparent cause
of a coincidence not happening,
then I would know the cause
of the coincidence and then there
wouldn't be any coincidence.
So that's the logic of it.
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
OK, but isn't like almost anything
totally unlikely at some level?
I mean like the fact that
we're even here, I mean,
that seems really improbable
to me, increasingly so actually
with each passing minute.
But what-- how did we wind up here?
Like mathematically
how did that happen?
It's still the one
minus not happening?
>> Joseph Mazur: You're not
serious about the question, are you?
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
Let me ask you.
No, there's a big debate,
there's a big debate
in the field of paleobiology--
>> Joseph Mazur: Yup.
>> Joel Achenbach: -- where
Stephen Jay Gould said
that if you rewound the
tape of evolution, you know,
going back 600 million years
and then run it forward again
you would not wind up with us --
>> Joseph Mazur: The same, yup.
>> Joel Achenbach: -- because
so many improbable things had
to happen for us to be here.
I mean, do you agree with that?
>> Joseph Mazur: I
think Stephen was not
around when the ultimate universe
theories came about really
and seriously it came about.
So, we can talk about ultimate
universes in the same light.
And then we're talking
about, you know,
we're talking some
serious physics there.
But--
>> Joel Achenbach: You mean
like quantum mechanics?
>> Joseph Mazur: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Joel Achenbach: So
tell us about that.
So there's that Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle.
I mean, from a mathematician
standpoint,
does that tell us that we--
>> Joseph Mazur: Well, James
Gleick just gave a lecture
on the time machine, right,
or going back in time.
I wasn't at the lecture
because I couldn't get
in when I tried to get in, but--
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: You know, maybe
if I go back to his lecture
that happened two hours ago, maybe
I'll get in again but anyhow.
Yeah, I mean it's a
question of interfering with,
you know, with the event itself.
So you're interfering
with the event.
The Heisenberg question that
you're asking is, you know,
you want to look at
something and you--
the fact that you're looking
at something actually
deserves that something.
So, how do you-- how do you actually
examine something in a real detail?
You're interfering with
something that's already happening
and something that exists.
So, there's something, you know,
could I undo a coincidence,
for example, which is I
think what you're asking.
Can I undo any coincidence
by the fact that we are here
and we're existing and we're
all together in this room?
Can I actually reduplicate
that if I went back in time
and just rewound the thing?
And I mean Stephen King's
wonderful novel was the "11/22/63"--
>> Joel Achenbach: Right.
>> Joseph Mazur: --
is fabulous for that.
I mean there's-- he has the answer,
if you've ever read
Stephen King's book.
It's just amazing to
think that, you know,
he does seem to know
the answer to that.
>> Joel Achenbach: Well, I think
we should take some questions.
They should be as mind-blowing
as possible, clearly.
All right.
And please phrase them in
a form of an-- of equation.
So, how do you want to do this?
Should I just-- should I just, OK.
>> Joseph Mazur: You have
people with microphones or--
>> Joel Achenbach: Come
to microphones, yeah.
It's a little blinding
so it's hard to see.
Yeah, go ahead.
>> Oh, thank you.
So, I have a-- I think it's a
bit silly question but it's you
as a scientist, what do
you think about all those
like pop psychology books
that like secret that tell us
that if we'll actually believe
in something somehow we
will like make it happen.
So, can we like provoke those
flukes like make those--
I don't know like by
focusing on something like--
do you think it's totally ridiculous
or is there actually some
maybe like matter to it?
Thank you.
>> Joseph Mazur: Yeah.
That's a really good
question, actually.
And the book talks a little
bit about that, in fact.
The question, the way I interpret
it is, you know, there is--
you can think something
is going to happen
and you're forcing it
to happen in some way.
But imagine it's possible that
your thinking is connected
to something about noticing.
So, a lot of coincidences that
happen to us just seem to happen
because we notice these things more.
Many of us don't seem
to find coincidence--
that coincidences don't
happen to us, let's say.
But if we actually notice,
we'll find that they
actually do happen to us.
So, just forcing yourself
to think, well, that's--
I think, I think is exactly the
same as just turning up the dial to,
your noticing dial, making it
a little bit more perceptive
and sharp.
So you're actually being much
sharper when you're noticing.
And I think these things
will happen.
>> How does the-- How does Satan,
God or maybe Zeus affect one's
perception of coincidence?
>> Joseph Mazur: How
is that-- what, sorry?
>> How does Satan, God
or maybe Zeus comes
into the experience of coincidence?
>> Joseph Mazur: Yeah.
I wish I could answer that.
If I could, I'd be a
famous author I think.
But I think that's something I toyed
with getting into and I realized
that that's something that's
kind of dangerous to get in to
and I didn't want to
move in that direction.
But I think that you, you know,
there is something
to that with that.
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
>> Yes. Thank you for coming.
I had a question.
You said earlier that
you'd categorize events
into 10 categories.
And I'm interested to knowing
what some of the 10 categories are
and how you did that
characterization
of putting the events
into these 10 events?
>> Joseph Mazur: Yeah.
Thank you for that question.
Well, the Joan Ginther
story is one of them.
That's about gambling.
So, all the coincidences of
gambling are in that category.
The lost book of-- the
book that was retrieved
by Anne Parrish is another category.
It's things that somehow
appear from a distant past.
The Anthony Hopkins story
is another category.
They don't totally intersect, those
stories, although they're both
about books and they're both--
there are some similarities.
Many of these categories do
intersect a little bit and I--
what I found is after I
wrote the book and I have
so many people coming to
me and writing me stories.
It is what happened.
Actually, the BBC interviewed me
for my British edition of the book
and the producer said we'd
like to put on our website
and Twitter feed the question to
you or question for our friends,
could you analyze the stories
that they will send us?
And I said sure.
Now, I didn't realize
this is the BBC.
So, the producer came
back with 10,000 stories.
I said look, I could do--
I'll do four of them.
And I was flooded with stories.
I was just-- it was just--
it was terrific to have them.
But-- And what I found was that
the new stories were trying
to be outside the 10 classes
that I've already decided
where the extremes of
all classes of stories.
And, you know, I think there
are maybe 11 or 12 classes now
of which I didn't think of.
I mean, I just got one
yesterday or the day before.
A guy lost a wallet on the
Staten Island Ferry just
over the overboard.
I don't know how you lose a
wallet overboard in Staten.
And he said a fisherman friend
of his six months later in--
on Cape Cod found his wallet.
Now, that is a category
all by itself.
But, you know, once you get
all these stories you have
to be very careful about putting
it into a non-fiction book.
So I have to vet those stories.
They really-- I mean, I
didn't know this person.
How do I make sure that's true?
It's such a wonderful story.
It's such almost impossible
story but yet, you know,
you have to vet these because
this is non-fiction book.
So, it's a-- there
are other categories
that I had not even thought about.
>> Joel Achenbach: Before
we go to the next question,
a question that's been rattling
around my head for a while is,
so we're coming to this
age of self-driving cars
which statistically we are
told will be much safer.
But I'd like to have my
hands on the wheel, you know.
I mean I like to be driving myself.
So, although I know
rationally that it's better
if the car drives itself, you know,
do I trust those algorithms
in there?
And I mean, you know,
isn't it human nature not
to really trust the math entirely
because it's different for me?
You know what I'm saying?
Does that make sense?
>> Joseph Mazur: Yeah,
but let's say this.
If you were being-- to be asked to
be an astronaut to go to the moon,
would you trust the thrusters
of that rocket ship that's going
to bring you to the moon?
>> Joel Achenbach: I'd
question the management at NASA.
>> Joseph Mazur: Yeah, you might
but you'd have to have that trust.
>> Joel Achenbach: Yeah.
>> Joseph Mazur: Because
you're not driving that thing.
>> Joel Achenbach: No, that's true.
>> Joseph Mazur: Yeah.
>> Joel Achenbach:
But that-- would you--
now you're being rational again.
All right, let's go ahead, OK.
>> I don't mean to make this
the religious question line
but when you're talking
about probability,
chance and as you brought
up here, we're here,
you have all these
probabilities, how is it possible.
You said you had gotten to points
where you thought about God
or spiritual influence and I was
curious about how far you went
with that considering the last
maybe 150 years there's a drought
of religion and science?
So, yeah, that was my question.
>> Joseph Mazur: Yeah.
It's something I have
thought about and I confess
that there are things
that we just don't know.
I mean, there are a lot of
things that we do not know.
I mean, if you think of
what the future has for us,
it's very hard to predict
the future.
I mean, 50 years ago,
would we have thought
that we could just all have
cellphones anywhere we go?
I mean, that's, you know, that
kind of thing is just so foreign
and we just wouldn't know that
there is actually some kind of a,
you know, an action at a
distance that gives everybody
in this room a telephone number
and they can all have
cellphones in their pockets.
I mean that's something
that's so extraordinary.
Why is it extraordinary?
Well, because I don't see any
attachments to these things.
I mean, I don't see the connections.
But how do we know that our
heads aren't really doing
something together?
It's possible and I wouldn't,
you know, I'm not saying this is,
you know, with any
conviction here but I am saying
that we do have electromagnet fields
go running around in our heads
or just the top of my head.
I mean, I can't feel it but I think
that there is an electromagnetic
field.
I mean, we are chemical
electric in circuitry.
>> Joel Achenbach: I can feel it.
>> Joseph Mazur: You can feel?
>> Joseph Mazur: Well,
but he has hair.
>> Joel Achenbach: But this close
to him, I mean it's as radiant.
I think we'll have to
wrap this up in a second.
>> Joseph Mazur: Yup.
>> Joel Achenbach: You know,
you already did your
book signing, right?
>> Joseph Mazur: I'm going
to do a book signing, yes.
>> Joel Achenbach: What
time is the book signing?
>> Six-thirty.
>> Joseph Mazur: Six-thirty.
>> Joel Achenbach: Six-thirty?
OK. He's doing a book signing.
I think we have time
for one last question
and then we'll play the linger
around and Joe will talk to--
>> Joseph Mazur: Yup.
>> Joel Achenbach: -- people
afterwards for a few minutes.
Last question.
>> If I may comment about why
people may not be better at math
or risk analysis in particular is
that obviously humans
are risk takers
and that has obvious advantages.
If Lindbergh knew the real odds of
his surviving the flight to Paris,
he wouldn't have done it.
All right.
But my real question has to do
with the scratch-off tickets.
And what is it about the printing
and things that allows you to win?
OK. You've never told us.
>> Joseph Mazur: Well, it is a bit
complicated and I really can't.
[ Laughter ]
There are schemes.
All I can say is there are
schemes where you adjust your--
the timing of your buying the ticket
to the place of buying the ticket
because you would know how many of
those tickets were already bought
and how many people
have not won so far.
And what-- And those people who
have won, you know what they won
because there is-- there are
gradations in the winnings.
So there's-- there are
techniques and algorithms,
they're not really algorithms,
they're just sort of rational smarts
that you have to figure out when
to buy the ticket, for scratch-off
that is, and where
to buy the ticket.
But that's a lot of work to be
done because you have to do a lot
of analysis of where
all those, you know,
7-11s are that you can
buy those tickets from.
And this doesn't only go
from one little locale.
It has to be in different places
in a state and different states.
So, it's a very broad thing
to do but it's a lot of work.
>> Joel Achenbach: Do
you play the lottery?
>> Joseph Mazur: I do not.
>> Joel Achenbach: OK.
That's the last question.
>> Joseph Mazur: I do
not play the lottery.
I bought one ticket in my
whole life, only one ticket,
and the reason was when I
wrote the book on gambling,
I wanted to know what
a ticket look like.
>> Joel Achenbach: All right.
The book is "Fluke".
Thank you very much.
>> Joseph Mazur: Thank you.
Thank you, Joel.
>> Joel Achenbach:
Thank you for coming.
Very good.
Thank you, thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.